Miss Carol uh you're on TV today Donald
Trump will also be on TV today he's
scheduled to appear uh not here uh but
on CNN with a Town Hall in New Hampshire
voters are going to have an opportunity
to ask questions of him at that town
hall what would you like voters what
questions or question would you like
voters to put to the former president in
light of this decision oh I can't I
can't imagine to me I don't think of
this as being political that is an
impossible question for me to answer but
I want to tell the people who are about
to watch CNN tonight Donald Trump did it
Donald Trump did it and
all his saying no no no
is not true